We raise our girls to believe
that they need to be quiet and agreeable,
that they need to follow rules and get in line,
to be pleasant,
to be amable,
to not be aggressive or defensive.
We call women with opinions jealous or petty,
women who stand up for themselves,
bitches or psycho.
And in some ways
we do the same thing to boys too.
We have a very narrow minded idea of what a man must be.
And we chip away at our boys until they fit that mold.
And then we wonder why they can't express themselves.
But with boys,
the men they grow into,
it seems to take their aggression out on others.
Whereas women,
we grow up believing that if we're not perfect,
we're not worthy of love.
And these messages are reiterated
and reiterated in our media,
in our magazines,
on social media,
in our movies.
And this issue is only amplified for people
who have to fight back against different stereotypes.
But the greatest lesson is women
that we can learn
is that you don't have to be perfect
to be worthy of love.
And that includes self love.